jumping
here from neural MMO
[Music]
all right that's all the stuff we have
to look at for now
so oh no wait is
there one more
okay where's
that
so oops say main gear
stuff give a quick overview of what we
were going to do here um we're working
on getting the Isaac Sim Isaac JY High
Fidelity physics simulator bound up to
puffer lib uh the problem is there about
three generations of PhD students worth
of terrible code associated with that so
we've been cleaning everything up we hit
tons of driver mesh Shenanigans which
took
another six
hours but I finally got those hopefully
fixed and now we just have to clean up
the Sim figure out what's going on and
we should be good to go
I got about let me think
today I got about 4 hours now and
probably another two hours after dinner
I got probably 6 hours to get all this
stuff
took way longer than I would have liked
to get my exercise in and get food and
stuff but went for a pretty hard run and
you know it takes time to
recover 916 Pace
5K um after literally 4 days of
training having been in the hospital
with pneumonia so I'll take that anytime
not
bad okay so we have our base
n and we have
this now I think there is a
synchronize step
Graphics draw a
viewer I think that there's a
synchronize missing isn't there
bad it's kind of
interesting that they uh they bind their
docks right to their distributed code
they don't host
them
uh I thought there's a graphic sync
function isn't
Graphics this should be if one is
displaying the simulation this
method okay so this is it here
here put this here
right test
3.8 okay so here we have our Bots um
they're actually they're hovering now
that's
interesting and if I
continue it goes
black the Scene goes
why first of all let's try not doing
these
actually you know what maybe
um maybe there's information we can use
in the
Sim you
GPU so everything goes to
Nan oops viewer
thing Sim time
step worker
here but um everything is Nan
all
man so why is
[Music]
that I guess the first thing to do would
be to
um see if we can get it to just render
basically just update the
render I got to wake up here
thought I got mostly enough
sleep I I guess I've been doing a fair
bit of work on this
lately takes a lot out of
you okay so there we go so
now um we are no
longer breaking stuff we have everything
in this position
here Sim the viewer and the
perf oh and yeah you actually you can
control
this uh so yeah here are all the Bots
they're all
floating they've been randomly colored
so actually they include a pretty nice
little renderer for this as
well this is the
humanoid it's got toe
flexors and pretty detailed hands I
guess yes yeah they're pretty darn
detailed
guess so
um why can't we do
anything if I do this it breaks
right instantly break so self Jim
simulate self. Sim
why does
that break
it that's my
email not like
that
we're just using this to see if there
are a
initialized prepare Sim is called before
stepping which it is
Sim
pams oh do we not have DT set no we do
it's right
here solver
type
this T made it
up that's funny as
hell and that's not
it at least on its own that's not it
maybe yeah I think that's what we do we
go to step up
here and we do
this oops actually other way
man actually maybe I need to do this
hold on
get
Jim what do you what do you think that
this uh this function is do you think it
exists or do you think jity made it up
rigid body
state is right
here well we just check this
I'm trying to think if the best thing
would just be to go line by line with
the
original I'm trying to think what stuff
I might have changed
it's very difficult to go line by line
with the original though because the
code is so
okay do we
um we create the ground plane first
surely
and this doesn't get called this gets
called by the [ __ ] parent
class um very
early I objectoriented programming needs
to be outlawed this is so horrible
okay what do we do we do acquire
gem we set a bunch of
used create
Sim which is where this calls the other
implementation and then prepare Sim is
down all the way down
here so it's really it's in create Sim
and then this calls super so we did we
set the up
AIS I think we do we set the up Axis in
the base
right
yeah and then we create the SIM
so that calls
super then we create the ground plane
which we just have way simpler
here
um but we now need to go look for
create round
plane to make plane
prams you make this and this is
fine and
then you have create
M's gives you square root num m and
spacing create
M's I think this is the more complicated
this so we have the root
here we get our
ARs and then we load
it and we get the num bodies rigid
count
yeah and
uh then we create this Force
sensor
spine torso
index then there's a bunch of stuff here
they don't use it looks
like and then they have this
Loop over num
Ms where they call create
M and then they begin Aggregate and then
they call build M and then end Aggregate
and then if we look at build n
we
have call
group filter and then we have this
file you call create
actor then you enable the
sensors and then you
I actually would prefer to do it like
this do the
color just one per
humanoid and then we
do
this drive
mode and then we set the
property and we also pend this handle
okay
stuff we get our
limits we send them to torch
we get their PD offset and
bodies
please hold
anything yeah no we're still we're still
uh failing
instantly that is something
you get all these
tensors root tensor
states create
rappers there's apparently a memory
thing that uh
you
collection it's funny that you can
uh you can do
this I wonder how much faster python is
without garbage
oops Yeah most languages have like a
weird way to mess with their garbage
collection
well I pretty much just want to finish
this and then pass out that would be the
best go to sleep at 400
p.m. that would be
tensors this is where you make all the
tensors
blank message from
twitch that's
every joint should have a velocity
parameter greater than zero
uh that's the one thing I cut out that I
thought was redundant
okay dude that's so
acquire is called before refresh
here and then do they
refresh hold on they're acquiring yet
okay so they have it what looks like
they have it
backwards
um so hold on this is refresh depth the
field actor route
net
contact so this should just be refresh
Sim
hey they fall through the
floor no they don't fall through the
floor
boom look at that we
win we
win that was so much freaking work to
get this stupid thing to like oh my God
and this is just the basics
wait this was just the basics but still
holy
hell
boink you're your
I'm almost finished with my buck shot
roulette and I still haven't played that
game
dqn would you be able to once
over yeah sure of course I'll look at
the
end you know if you buy if you get it
into a a
gym API gymnasium API uh you can just
run puffer lib on it out of the box and
then you'll know whether it's the M or
the uh the algorithm that's giving you
trouble because like we have a nice
stable po implementation it's really
fast you can just run it against your
environment it's literally a oneline
binding for existing gymnasium
environments welcome to all the YouTube
folks we just got this thing
boom I thought it was on Steam is it
online as
well not playing it on stream obviously
obviously
but there're the
robots
Okay we have
robots humanoid
thingies I don't do much just
yet next we try to get the actions doing
something
works I would like to rotate them so
that they uh they're standing up by
quat D I love how it just waste all
these tokens and takes forever giving
you an annoying code
okay initial pose so we just have to
rotate this is probably because we have
the Z axis
up or whatever
case need to get the
uh and stop the actions for a second so
I can see
it's one of these it's probably around
the Z isn't
it X
zyx so it's this
[Music]
perfect Bonk
ah hey
Spencer send this to K real quick
whoops so this will be initial perf with
only eight of
them 29 SPS God okay let's see if we
can't bring that up a a little bit holy
okay and then we would do
like realistically we're going to have
4096 of these
right 21,000 so that's unusably
bad we definitely have to bring that up
though we're only getting um 10,000
before so deleting a bunch of wrapper
stuff did
help I
believe is this one of those M's where
you really need to crank this to get a
perf let me
see let's see if this doubles
it waiting let me see
if it's low man we're just going to
teach you how to do some performance
engineering like you'll you're smart
enough you'll pick it up
fast okay so it doesn't help above
um above a certain
threshold so we'll use
4096 I mean being good at writing fast
code is very very very very
useful and often fast code ends up just
being simple code as well which is
nice occasionally you got to do some
fancy caching but usually it's not that
hard
so there are a few things I want to do
here
if I load them all into the same
scene on a GPU
yeah
see kind of use GPT as some docks
I'm getting about
100 you have to try to make stuff that
slow
man you're in good company or along with
like top RL researchers doing that stuff
but yeah you're straight
trolling assuming you mean M Speed not
training
this well dude write a perf test on your
environment it's not that hard like look
do this it's like 10
lines and always multiply by number of
Agents cuz it's agent steps per
second it's multi-agent
it turns out compute clusters is
completely [ __ ] they got hacked in our
manually pulling Plows in are you
kidding
me that freaking
nation state level
attack
lovely can you send them back um a
patriot missile as a present
the most valuable of research is the
curriculum learning it solves all of RL
well now you got no excuse to uh to not
go use your
ridiculously expensive uh University gym
cuz you've got [ __ ] all else to
do no experiments are
go for a run or something man
like I don't know you can't do [ __ ]
about
that I did a about a 916 Pace 5K today
with four days of training since
pneumonia I'll take that
true I just added a kilometer a day this
week from 2 to
5 I I think it's the lack of weight it
like cuz it feels really easy running
but my heart rate's literally at
185 so I don't know it's kind kind of
weird usually at 185 I'd be dying so I
don't
know all right Zoomer yeah yours goes to
205 or
whatever mine goes to like
190 low 190s I
think lighter yeah I want to get the
mass back though
I get uh the rack will arrive in about
two weeks and then I get to start doing
my stuff
again oh man I did I went down that
route in undergrad I
uh I had like four monsters a day for
most of
undergrad and probably more more in
alcohol than that
out we got uh Isaac Jim running in
puffer no not at the same
time look at
this
Jesus got to get some cardio in man
lower that [ __ ] that's ridiculous
yeah it's not running this is flopping
around this is just random
actions ah yeah I remember okay that's
rough it's got to be something
man is there no way around that
[ __ ] cuz not doing exercise will also
kill you
that I think there was some US president
who literally like trained himself half
to death and like cured his asthma
though that's uh probably apocryphal
months does it actually cure it after uh
a certain duration of
time is that how it
works nine more months of 2.5 years in
is that how it works it just it takes
like like nearly three and a half years
but then you then it's cured is that a
is that a
works I kind of get what he means though
cuz like I they gave me basically the
same thing and that [ __ ] sucks it just
it instantly spikes your heart rate but
it only spikes it by like 10 or 15 I'm
pretty sure so if it's 98 resting I
think your normal resting is also very
high it's about what mine was before I
started doing any
this it reduces it enough Oh okay that's
cool yeah your normal's probably high
because you can't do
cardio is just what it's going to
see you best of luck
Ryan that's some [ __ ] I wish I could
help you out but I definitely don't have
enough spare puffer boxes at the
moment once I have the 40 then I will be
very happy to support some cool research
with you
yesh that's such
[ __ ] it's cool that it eventually
gets cured but that's like [ __ ] hell
well you can at least do some
powerlifting in the meantime and get
plenty jacked it actually it takes way
longer to do um strength training than
cardio like you know it's like a couple
years for most people like if you have
average genetics and you're not like
super heavy it takes like a good 2 years
to get a two-plate bench
press um
and usually like longer to get like a th
total took me like four for that though
I was also running only takes a year to
be running marathons from like nothing
jeez I mean at least there's stuff you
can carry for that it's not pleasant but
you have it
on we are currently working on this High
Fidelity physics Sim Isaac gem we're
getting this bound up to puffer lib
which is my ultra high performance
reinforcement learning library and we're
cutting out all the dog [ __ ] code that's
uh surrounding this thing so you can
actually use it in a way that makes
sense is what we're currently doing
this stream is pretty much just all the
reinforcement learning Dev I do goal is
this year for puffer to make RL 10 times
easier to get working on new
problems I think we will hit
that it's just I'm just sending it
random actions for testing that's no big
deal that's easy to
fix um now the question is why do I only
see one of
these
Char create
actor
group I do
guys enable for
sensors then you set the color
set this I only see one of these
guys in the
on well actually that's not going to
tell me anything because I don't know if
it's actually running these
I do something wrong
here college student watching videos for
Linux commands and saw the
video yeah man hey if you're looking to
get into some cool RL stuff we got lots
of people you just need to be able to
code know if you can write some code you
can kind of start jamming some RL takes
people like a month or two to really get
onboarded and start writing some cool
stuff it's pretty
quick $600 down to 461 that's
good less code for same thing is
better usually unless you're
golfing spread out humanoids in a
grid could that be it it's literally
just they're all on top of each
other hang on
I'll feel kind of stupid if it's
that there should be uh more of these
guys
here create
actor 0 yeah oh wait wait you got to do
I forget it's a
unique I forgot about
that you're writing in
Python uh so this rapper code is iny
python puffer lib itself which is the
main library I develop the learning and
stuff is in Python with pytorch but all
of the environments so the majority of
the library is in C so all these
environments together about 20,000 lines
of c and uh you can play them on puffer
doai you can watch these agents play you
just hold shift you can take over for
the agent and try to you know play for
them take my hands off the agent takes
over from very simple to like very very
complex this is a miniature
MMO I mean this is a mooba something
like mini League of Legends or mini
DOTA we got lots and lots of stuff on
here this stuff has to be python though
because it's a library with a python API
so I wonder if they do have a a I don't
think they have
um I guess technically if it's in
C++ we could just not use the python
API but I think that they have like I
don't know I might have to look into
that it doesn't really save anything for
the
initialization I don't really want to
invest that heavily in this specific
specific framework though um client is
interested in this a few people are
interested in this but this is not I
don't think Isaac Jim is like still
fully the dominant platform I think that
there are like a few more now that
people are interested in so it doesn't
really make sense to go super super Ham
on this I'm going to get this like I've
cut this from over 2,000 lines down to
about a th000 2,000 being like the
standard rappers that they provide um so
it's I've made it a lot simpler but I
think digging into this C++ API and like
rewriting sections of that is where I
draw the
line okay so this is
still humanoid
zero oh wait cuz this is got to be num
actors
in I only deal with networking Scripts
I mean you can do lots of things
right uh
n agent should be
defined of num
actors okay oh wait there they are look
at them
weird right they're spread out kind of
weird I think that's because of the
randomness or the uh the offsets
maybe what if I do
this whoa
okay they're not supposed to collide
like
that that's kind of funny
confetti let me see how I get them uh to
not collide
this was in the user guide but I didn't
understand what they were
saying not very
nice little bit of
promo for folks watching literally all
the stuff I'm working on is free and
open source it's community-led so you
can get involved you don't have to deal
with terrible stuff like this we uh
we're very happy to have people just
writing fun M's and uh I mean that
actually really helps the science side
believe it or not you can it's pretty uh
it's actually pretty quick to learn how
to write like really high perf M's like
this and to get into some of the
URL uh codes right here you can start to
help us out really helps out a ton you
can join the Discord this is where we
organize everything and you can follow
my ex for more content including some
articles on RL we've got quick start
guides for newcomers all sorts of fun
stuff don't forget to feed the puff for
a star
back to
code well as soon as I figure this API
out that
is simulation
setup so we
have environment collection is pack
multiple instances of an environment
into a single simulation
space we'll get arranged in a 2d gr run
row at a time
possibly so I think Isaac Jim
potentially does this for
this okay Collision group is an integer
that identifies the Collision group to
which they will sign they'll only
Collide if they belong to the same
Collision
group in certain
cases You may wish to set up more than
one Collision
group a bit Mask two bodies will not
Collide if their Collision filters have
a common bit
set presentent certain kinds of objects
in a scene from interacting
physically Collision
filter so I think we look for create
actor and let's see if we get more about
the Collision
filter for elements
to mask off
Collision
maybe hold on
no will not Collide if their Collision
groups share no common
maybe maybe this does work hold on
do these look like they're colliding or
are they just
like no these are definitely
colliding right these are definitely
colliding with each
other I mean we can double check this
very
two yeah see they all spread out that
means they're getting
like this is what it would look
like yeah is this what it looks like if
there's no
Collision yeah cuz they're all
like these are not there no Collision
there's no Collision filter here you can
see that they're all like
overlapped um so I don't think I'm
understanding the way that the filter
works I don't think GPT is
either is a bit MK that lets you filter
out collisions between
bodies two bodies will not Collide if
their Collision filters have a common
bit
set does that work I think that's
different
right versus hold on versus this
yeah see how quickly these
separate these separate incredibly
quickly whereas these ones do
not see there's still
like I think this
works and I think that what we do now is
we test the
performance now it's possible that this
is not any FAS
I think that I'm barking up the wrong
tree here though because I think what
happens is Isaac Jim actually sticks all
the agents in one environment uh
better no longer
exceeded user aggregate
size carb gy
this okay that is a lot faster um but
but we need to test
something uh let me think how I want to
do this this I think I'm going to very
carefully
undo all of this which I just
carefully copy it redo
everything and then I'm going to do
this and I'm going to just
make some small
changes
yeah
okay environment new
n.p old
n environment. pi and now we're going to
do group will be zero and filter will be
one on all of them
71 so you get a very small perf boost it
looks like let me make sure that that
was the case
environment old
and
so I will put a comment
here you
get small per boost three
four
4% putting all
so that's
nice we get
this get AIS
perams what's the model giving you line
complete super maven
I really like it it's I have two total
plugins in neoen one is super Maven and
the other is Sami which just gives you a
couple extra syntax highlights in
yeah everyone has vs code ones right but
not everybody has a neovin plugin I
don't think co-pilot has a a nice neoen
plugin it's really easy to get this one
working so I like it
it's also very fast um it gives you your
code completes very
quick I like
it okay 75k steps per second is
decent
at least when I got it it was way better
than co-pilot for that I don't know
about
this
next they cap your
amount you really don't need you really
don't need that for code completion is
the thing like you shouldn't be using it
for full functions you should be using
it for line completion and for that you
don't need a crazy
model honestly if anybody wants a free
startup idea integrate an LSP properly
with uh code completions it'll make it
way better and way faster
they cap the number of completions you
get
wow that's annoying I yeah I pay for
super Maven Pro and it's not capped as
far as I'm aware
what we don't need any of that [ __ ] hold
on can I just do this
that should be faster you would
think I guess since there's no self
contact and there's nothing close it
doesn't matter
Keys
No how do I get the names for this
get actor doof
properties I here this is how you get
the name
The Hope here is that um by reducing the
degrees of freedom here it should get a
lot
faster okay so
here yeah you see this is a lot of
degrees of
freedom uh thumb ring pinky middle
thumb index
middle you forgot
ring oh no
this what's your plan for this PP yeah
there's a little bit of extra client
stuff on this one um but it's
Sim the hand should not be uh the finger
should not be flopping
fingers are still flopping around it
looks like to me
see Max number of
shapes flag to enable so this doesn't
exist made that [ __ ] up
I could comment the joints but I think
then you get a I think you just get
missing
hand if you do
that double check
DMS nothing yet what time is it should
be 130
sufficient block
points for
H see this is tricky because a lot of
the compute right now is just going into
the hands and we do not care about those
for this it's kind of funny that they've
got like this relatively blocky humanoid
and then they have the hands fully
articulated like
is this even
working remove stiffness remove damping
do should actually we should see the
hand being like locked we're not seeing
that's not
working it's hard to freaking see but
actually
look
orientation well it's going to be
oriented because differently because um
know the whole B is moving around
okay hang
on are the fingers
moving you should
do 05 maybe
or might be too
much are the individual fingers moving
here
can't tell it's not moving the wrist
either
though it looks like it could
be oh here's an easy way to
tell we can just
um does this look different
see
stiffness damping
range it's a joint
free
joint body
joint toe is a joint
that's
tricky I don't think we can really mess
with this because I think that the Gen
well
okay this is a little tricky because
we're losing I think at least half of
the performance to um we're losing at
least half of the performance right here
to the uh the excessively articulated
hands
I do have it running at 70k which is
better than
before I think that's going to have to
just be the perf optimization I do for
now is just what I've done here
um cuz I think I got to get like OBS and
other stuff cleaned
up yeah I'm going to take a couple quick
minutes use the restroom um and think
about what I'm going to do and then I'll
be back and we will clean up the rest of
this um get maybe observations stuff
like that uh I'll leave some
placeholders for some other stuff and we
will be set be right back
go we do good work here we fix things
this is what we
do okay uh so next I'm not Computing
observations yet
want so they
do root H OBS local body
pause body rote body contact
buff they actually have a pretty big
observation
space go check the
paper we'll look at this
paper what we're using for observations
States consists of the input motions
next
pose along with the difference between
the input next pose and the current
simulated pose across multiple
aspects don't give it the current pose
a
line okay
so joint
rotation
position joint velocity and
velocity so the joint
rotation the position
got to be a joints
right velocity an angular
control reward function is designed to
encourage make reward
energy penalty and an adversarial
reward difference between simulated
pose and the input
okay energy penalty regulates the
policy adversary reward encourage
is distribution of simil
motions
ah I
see so
that's a little tricky
so these are the only
variables if I get these
variables then we can do whatever
and this is really what you would want
this is Joint rotation position velocity
angular velocity so this is all the
stuff and they probably have it
local body pause velocity angular
velocity so I just have to figure this
function
out and then they have this crazy reward
but this is from a different paper
right what I should do is I should check
the other paper and see how it's
different and see what they say that
this is
hopefully they tell you what their
observations
are stay
eight
simulate local position rotation
velocity and rotational
velocity is it wait local position
rotation
velocity rotation position velocity and
angular so these are the same
thing local position rotation velocity
o so they should actually have all the
things I need in
um body pause body Rod body
velocity angular
velocity so why is there so much stuff
going on here local root OBS root height
OBS contact
local body
pause root pause
expand okay I see so you want to get rid
of the global coordinate which is
fine then flat local body pause
and then they rotate
it I don't know why they do
so this extracts the root body
position calculates The Heading
rotation converts body positions to
local coordinates relative to
root there's root
position joint rotations
linear and angular
velocities joint
positions joint
rotations joint velocities
angular
velocities and contact
forces root
height I
see so I can just use this I
think this is a confused
function I think I can just use this and
get rid of contact forces and root
OBS so this has some extra stuff I don't
need but this is actually kind of fine
let me see if I can get this to actually
run
reward not
needed wait where's the freaking
humanoid
OBS I'm being stupid they should
beute
observations
here yeah yeah yeah so this should go
here observation
do
does we get this and we get observations
cool
equals here your
humanoids obs
it 1 by
7 78 that's not correct because that
that's for
one one agent I
assume um
Ms Point let see if the tensors going in
are
problem I know why it's by
one you see yeah that's
weird I think the shapes got messed up
because I re ordered the environment a
little
bit it should just be numb agents is how
it should
work so
um yeah let's sort that
out cuz any like the other anything else
is
silly oh are we going to be able to
reset
individual only it matters if we can
reset individual agents for this
actually does
it we can
anyways yeah we should be able to do
that
anyways it's not going to be any worse
than resetting an
environment should be fine
States what shape does it give you for
this
I yeah so that's actually freaking
perfect it gives you this in the exact
format you'd want
um num
actors yeah so this is what we call a
stupid
because this is the same thing so let's
get rid of
this we already have no actor so we
don't need this
[ __ ] and inial humanoid root
States we're just going to call Initial
root
States and then I don't know why they
zero this but
sure humanoid actor
IDs numb actors
factors so that's
easy do
anymore doof
pause okay this is potentially
legitimate let's see what what this
this okay that's
correct shall I see what they're trying
to do
yeah this is a very
screwy thing to
do so this should be num actors DF per
actor like this would work
right
no hang
on am I wrong here oh no no no because
it is a size two
active de deal
of ah okay so there does it does have a
two and
then we do
do View
BF uh I don't know about this
yet num
B is
153 so I literally just need to this is
just self. n
we do initial doof
pause and then
this we don't really care about the
force
tensors
and see we got rigid body State
here bodies per
Enis
probably they're vastly over
complicating little
o
rigid body state
shape num
M's bodies per
see
factors let 16
does I'm trying to just clean this all
up
actor
shape okay so this does actually work
out
view you and let just pull
in Num body
yes
B
per but this is still also num
bodies so this is SN
bodies
and then this
is look how silly these people are
silly you see how it's like everywhere
you
look there's just like completely
unnecessary complexity for no reason
um there should be no contact
forces so I think we can just remove
these we do we need the force
tensor I think we'll keep this for
we'll have to fix a couple small things
I'm
sure probably somebody using those
contact
forces I mean really like this is what
happens when you just dig into academic
code it's like you just cut it away and
cut it away and cut it away and then
there's almost nothing left
and you've just been like suffering on a
mountain of stupidity of your own
creation because you didn't
respect the utility of actually writing
decent
code that I can just keep doing science
the code doesn't matter Yeah the code
matters it's a very common trap for
um
academics undervaluing the engineering
side it's really the most useful thing
there
is I mean just being able to build
whatever you want and have everything be
clear and
simple well science isn't taught
either right
you really have to learn that
yourself like how to actually think
scientifically that
takes takes some number of years of
experience
right but
there's I don't know it's kind of
bizarre me get rid of contact
forces I'm just going to get rid of
these
and the body
IDs hey bet we've been back man this is
like hour I don't know six of the stream
Maybe
sorry
mate you're good dude you're not
obligated to hang on on my
stream hey how's it going um I'm getting
better I ran a 9116 Pace 5K today after
4 days of training since uh so not
terrible um it's going to take you know
some number of months to get my old
level of Fitness back but at least I can
run if I'm careful I'll be a able to
start doing compound uh lifts in a
couple of weeks and we'll see from
there yeah I mean it's I'm going to have
access to some nice equipment which will
be good I'm ordering um a ton of good
gemm equipment I'm getting like a very
nice power rack I'm getting a deadlift
platform for here I already have some
like okayish adjustable dumbbells
um so we're going to get some nice stuff
going to go from there and I'm just
getting Kung DMs
Sol speed up with Isaac
Jim also scon
compiling that compiles
for that compiles for the whole so um
this Branch here that I'm working on uh
I have to check if the scon compiles it
I think it does it's an old python
version so I got to double check some
stuff but yes for the main like 20 that
all
works oh yeah yeah yeah okay toen this
is you I forget everybody has freaking
different names um yeah but the thing is
it'll after you compile it once it'll
cach everything so it'll only compile
your Robo
if the full compile works like you're
good because it'll cach everything so
it'll take a couple minutes to compile
the first time and then it'll just
yeah just doing a little uh little stuff
here chatting with K on how to get this
thing
but apparently I'm loading the wrong
bot um which is actually good news
because once I fix it it'll be way
faster we don't need the stupid finger
actuators
works
right yeah this works Bonk
dude I got to register to download an
XML no we'll find it
okay it's this
dude I guess I do have to do
well we're fine because we are uh I mean
this is open source research
oh that's
cool that's nice of them they added me
as an author on um on GPU
drive it's fair I've done a ton of work
not getting uh any emails from them I
thought that this was supposed to
didn't I actually get the freaking
file I thought I had the
changed I might te you just keep your
email alums just get to keep their
emails it's kind of nice Stanford there
like not for
alums like no we'd like to have our
alums which is smart
only
motor position velocity
actuators
supported let see
no I deleted
garbage this is a different model as
well we just have to it just needs some
MIT likes it when you keep they actually
are pretty good about
that not pinching a couple pennies
clearing email
also it's very weird that it spams this
on uh on
load like it spams it on load is very
weird asset
load what if I just look for load asset
in this repo
no they don't have load AET does this
thing
download
models models and dependencies
yeah it's just GitHub being
stupid
um small asset
file small asset
projectile we don't want block
projectile we want the
angular damping yeah this is literally
everyone copying each other's
code so we got asset root asset file
asset
mesh automatically
create the simple humanoid
same now this is a different
model yes because it's from a Joko
it's how are there more degrees of
freedom in this bloody thing
space uh we're not going to know the
observation space I
think for a bit to
do fix
this action space is going to
be NF I
believe and uh I guess we'll
see ref
we're not going to know this until we uh
we get it from the model so that's fine
oops and then
body
contact so we got key bodies
here and these are going to be
different so let's see
if this has a
config simple
humanoid okay this doesn't
have this is
simple
shape do we have the
bodies
anywhere key bodies
I guess I can get this from
the
task config of key Bodies Okay so it is
in a
config uh we just don't know which
yeah want
config
bodies I think this is simple humanoid
here
well here for testing
purposes if we just do
zero they still do that well I think
that the action mode is
none was that what I had it as
before no
I think there's this reset bodies thing
as well hang on I missed something
here so this is all the thing things in
here I think if we were to do
what
exactly does CPP change about C to make
it worse it's not that it changes
anything specific for RL it's just that
people tend to like just write shittier
code um and I don't want to deal with
that
language it's just much easier to just
write the damn stuff and
say like I'm not going like I'm just not
dealing with people like throwing
arbitrary C++ at me and like reviewing
and dealing with that I'm just not doing
it you know it's very very easy to write
the environments and see the way we're
doing it it's very very very easy to
make sure everything is incredibly
fast you
know I mean we literally I have a
project I'm supporting that's written in
like C in the C C++ GPU accelerated game
engine but and on GPU they're getting
50,000 frames per second and that's
after I've optimized the hell out of it
I could write it in about the same
amount of Cod Inc and it would run a
million in fact we're probably going to
help Port
this isn't
here what do they do
differently you would think it should be
in the
setup Jesus there's so much freaking
code how do you write 1,700 lines of
code and then go to sleep saying yeah I
just a good amount of code do right
that's totally the amount of code that
you take to do
say projectile acids okay they're doing
something different here maybe they do
need a little more code I doubt they
need that much more code
though
tens where's the
humanoid robot config
I don't know
[Music]
man I kind of suspected as much you know
I don't I didn't think like yeah the RL
devs and Robotics are magically going to
be way better than the rest of the field
so yeah of course they likewise just
have a bunch of terrible code
andet create okay so
here robot
they have just a ton of parameters you
need to load
in this is so slow they decided to
multiprocess it that's hilarious
and kind of
sad asset real
asset
options so when you load asset Road
asset file and asset
options that's it unless there's
anything else they add in
here oh this is all they load in
so
joints four sensor joints here and it
would be left and right ankle otherwise
and do
lle or
humanoid
asset drive
mode if I do
I like I don't know what else there is
in here that I'm
missing guys this is where you load the
ass at
I wonder if I can Benchmark it at
least this
works I know Sim is pretty heavy yep
that's what we expect
145,000 but I really have no idea what
the hell's wrong with this and I got to
go to dinner
soon I really would like to fix this
today if I can give um Kung something
stable to deal with
yeah this has been a
lot 25 hours and two
days most likely on
this we're pretty close here honestly
um it's just like I loaded in we had the
wrong model so I loaded in a new model
and I'll show you what happens it's fast
but it does this
it's less hilarious when you have to
[ __ ] debug this hor
[ __ ] 145k is nice though
we'll actually be able to train it close
to that I imagine we should get we
should get over 100,000 training even
with the netw Le for the smallest
one I don't know if Kung is watching if
you have any idea what's wrong with this
thing but I got no idea no you can't
just step through it that's the thing
because it just goes into some like
massive
let me grab this
function just to
test it might be this because the
model's different
on we'll we'll undo this garbage code if
we uh if we fix this if this fixes it
rather um r R PD
is
see build
PD and this gets called
in right after you load the
model
load and we
do
build
okay and then
names body name is
onear
oh my
[Music]
this dude what the [ __ ] is
this like actually what is
okay bumping Neil I don't know what that
is
I mean these are all on
zero so I don't see how zero doesn't do
anything I don't think you need this
crazy ass PDX
yeah it's just not a fun
time I'm just straight up not having a
good time with this
one we need that but we'll
see what do they do with
I'm trying to think
what what it would
be they give me joint
limits a while
ago set doof Drive I think it made this
freaking function up as the problem I
think it loves to make up API [ __ ] that
just doesn't exist
so this get
set get do properties and then you can
set stiffness and
okay now the question is is that a good
solution or not
away a
lot but there's still weird [ __ ] going
on
H you're not going to enjoy your
algorithms course
then or your Advanced algorithms course
at least the theoretical
one it's okay I hated that one
yep usually taking junior or senior year
you can take it earlier if you want I
took it freshman
spring not a fun
course I mean it's perfectly fine if
you're anywhere decent at proof-based
mathematic Buton
okay so they just wobble if you do
this if you
do they still fly
away that seems
good and then if I do like five then
they probably Fly Away
don't I think that was it I have no idea
why this is needed in this one and not
the other one but going be
this yes yes it
am that's
stupid DN well
hope a little
stupid a little stupid sometimes
very
nice okay 886
lines and uh there are a few things
we're not we're still going to be able
to cut
there we go 884
lines add
okay so for folks on YouTube uh I will
be back after
dinner in the meanwhile though if you're
interested in ultra high performance
reinforcement
learning getting involved in the space
it's easier than you might
expect all my stuff is here on puffer
doai all the
environments right here we've built all
these they're all Ultra Ultra fast you
can play them in your browser you can
watch Agents play them in your browser
you can hold shift and you can play them
yourself they go from very simple to
very very complex here's aobo with
economy and
trade here's a MOA an MMO I mean before
here's a MOA like League of Legends or
DOTA pretty nice
environments if you want to see the code
you can help us out a ton star the repo
it's free really
helps join the Discord if you want to
get involved with Dev or use the project
and if you're looking for more content
we have a bunch of articles on the blog
here but there are also some that you
can only find on my X account where I
post all sorts of reinforcement learning
stuff back in a bit thanks for tuning in
and see you around